my name is Sarah aankhen and i'm from  seymour indiana i graduated from Trinity  Lutheran High School in 2012 and now I'm  a junior at Hillsdale College majoring  in politics and mathematics this spring  I'm interning for the Heritage  Foundation Center for principles and  politics in Washington DC through the  Washington Hillsdale internship program  the Washington Hillsdale internship  program we call whip for short we bring  anywhere between 10 to 20 students a  semester out to DC they take two or  three classes and they in turn on the  hill at the Heritage Foundation really  anywhere they want to we find somebody  coming out of college who has some  practical real-world experience  especially experience that applies to  what we do it really sets them apart  Washington is one of those places that  kids can learn a lot and gain a lot just  from being here for a few months and  that sense coming here and having that  internship experience i can guarantee  will be life-changing